Ми ще до початку війни почали обладнувати пункт укриття,
а зараз це вже переходить на пункт обігріву та пункт незламності.
Мешканці цього київського ОСББ склалися грошима і закупили усе необхідне для того,
щоб їхня багатоповерхівка на близько пів тисячі квартир стала автономною
за відсутності будь-яких комунальних благ: світла, опалення, електрики та води.
На сьогоднішній момент у нас є польова кухня, генератор трифазний, де 7 кВт.
Також у нас є 60 ліжок, ліжкомісць, 30 ліжок двоярусних.
У нас є 10 тонн запасу води та дві станції фільтрації для приготування питної води.
Головна мета - не дати будинку замерзнути.
Тому зараз планують купити ще один великий генератор на 50-60 кіловат, щоб котельня могла працювати автономно.
Якщо нам вдасться купити великий генератор - у нас буде тепло. І ліфт буде працювати.
Буде тепло і буде вода. Вистачить тепла від цього генератора на дві котельні, на два теплопункти,
на освітлення місць загального користування і на підкачку насосів для води.
У підвалах для людей облаштували укриття.
Тут є ліжка, опалення, електрика й інтернет.
За таких умов у підвалі можна провести від кількох днів до кількох тижнів.
Своє укриття ОСББ навіть вирішило подати у офіційний реєстр "Пунктів незламності".
Пункти незламності, пункти обігріву. Їх ще не було, як ми вже працювали.
Зараз, коли вже стало питання по кожному району, де, скільки, в якому районі скільки пунктів обігріву, я його подав у реєстр.
Мені хочеться, щоб люди бачили, і відповідно кожен подумав:
а давайте ми хоч собі зробимо, може, не так менше, але це було би і для людей,
і менше навантаження було на ту саму державу. Держава – це ми.
Тому під час блекауту сюди пукатимуть й інших мешканців міста.
Скільки в нас місць вистачить - ми стільки людей і пустимо.
На кілька годин зарядити. У нас вайфай тут є, але він зараз від провайдера. Але в нас уже є старлінк.
І ми зараз зробимо розводку і в нас на перших поверхах в обох секціях буде вайфай, і тут буде вайфай.
У цей "Пункт незламності" вже привезли гуманітарну допомогу для тих, хто прийде сюди зігрітися.
Чайник, стаканчики, чай, цукерки, шоколадки, тут є і печиво, вода.
Ну, і засоби гігієни: паперові рушники, дитячі памперси, памперси для дорослих, мило і тому подібне.
Потурбувалися в ОСББ і про питну воду. У власній насосній поставили спеціальні фільтри.
Тут розташовані баки, вони заповнені. Тут 5 тонн води у кожній секції.
Це друга секція, є ще перша секція, там також 5 тонн води.
Ось стоїть зворотний осмос, який видає 30 літрів на хвилину. Він виготовляє нам питну воду.
Вже нафільтровані там є бочки, там вже 210 літрів питної води стоїть.
Для польової кухні вже закупили дрова, а у підвалі встановили буржуйки,
які допоможуть не лише обігріти приміщення, а й закип’ятити воду.
Те, що ви бачили з вулиці, трубу, оце буржуйка.
Вона розрахована на 50 квадратних метрів обігріву.
Таких буржуйок буде встановлено чотири.
Одна тут, одна навпроти і дві в передній частині.
Це ми перший такий пробний зробили тест. Добре гріє, розпалювали її вже.
У такому укритті зможе розміститися до тисячі людей.
Разом із підвалом тут є ще два спортзали, які також можна займати.
Ви можете подивитися: тут у нас душова є, є туалет.
Отут люди прямо на цих матах, вони теплі, вони прямо на цих матах лежали, діти бігали.
Для того, щоб мешканці будинку спокійно пережили зиму, ОСББ вже інвестувало пів мільйона гривень.
Власний "Пункт незламності" вони створили ще до того, як такі центри по всій країні почала ініціювати влада.
Нині на інтерактивній карті позначено вже понад 4 тисячі "Пунктів незламності".
Це місця для тимчасового перебування, де за тривалого відключення електроенергії чи тепла
обіцяють безкоштовний доступ до електрики, опалення, інтернету, води та аптечок.
Вранці мені заледве вдалося зловити кілька поділок мережі, щоб дізнатися, де поруч є такі пункти незламності.
І врешті понад кілометр я йшла сюди, щоб впіймати бодай кілька поділок мережі, щоб зв’язатися з близькими,
щоб погрітися і взагалі випити бодай якогось чаю. Тому що ми вже живемо без світла понад добу.
Щоправда, не всі "Пункти незламності", позначені на мапі, були готовими до прийому мешканців.
Багато з них не відкрилися або не були забезпечені усіма обіцяними благами.
Через це президент Володимир Зеленський навіть дорікнув київській владі за "профанацію"
і погане забезпечення "Пунктів незламності" у столиці.
На критику з боку президента мер Києва Віталій Кличко відповів, що в нинішній ситуації
не хоче вступати в політичні баталії і повідомив, що в столиці облаштовані та працюють понад 430 пунктів обігріву.
А на випадок надзвичайної ситуації готуються оперативно розгорнути ще понад 100 пунктів.
Тим часом українці знаходять альтернативні варіанти - кав’ярні з генераторами чи коворкінг-центри.
Ми підключили невеличкий генератор, який у нас уже був у доступі.
І ми зараз чекаємо на великий генератор на 100+ кіловат, він майже як машина за розміром.
Він у нас буде біля парковки розташований.
А зараз ми просто на терасу підключили невеличкий генератор, пустили багато подовжувачів,
і в цій зоні зараз, в якій ми знаходимося, всі працювали.
У таких місцях люди можуть не лише провести кілька годин, щоб зарядити ґаджети і випити чаю, а й повноцінно працювати.
Саме в цьому коворкінгу в нас є, в принципі, всі можливості для того, щоб працювати ефективно,
для того, щоб не зупиняти свою роботу і продовжувати комунікувати.
Ми практично тут живемо. У нас тут є і капсули для сну, і душові, і кава, і вайфай, і все на світі.
Допомагати українцям готовий і відповідальний бізнес.
Дедалі частіше магазини, аптеки, заправки, банки, поштові відділення та ресторани
долучаються і відкривають у себе "Пункти незламності".
Перелік адрес можна знайти на онлайн-карті.
Там можна зігрітися і зарядити пристрої. Інші ж послуги надають за окрему плату.